welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and obi-wan kenobi as a secret
obi-wan and leia series shows us really
the early days of leia organa and her
experiences with ben kenobi and tala and
the inquisitors in the mysterious path
all of these elements stacking the
kindling for what will later grow into a
spark of rebellion a fire that will burn
in this woman for decades we are the
spark that'll light the fire that'll
burn the empire down the empire the
empire we're not at the first order yet
but the embers glowing and young leia
are about to catch on a tinderbox of
rage across the galaxy a ground swell of
rebellion fanned by heroes like ahsoka
tano cassian andor bail organa mon
mothma the crew of the ghost and yeah
sure that farm boy from tatooine and in
this episode of between the duels let's
look at star wars movies and shows
written materials to figure out who
really started the fire or if it was
always burn and since vader's flesh was
burning in some ways the rebellion began
in the defiance obi-wan saw in leia's
eyes on daiyu in on mapuzo the face he
saw was that of padme amidala was your
friend a jedi too
no she was a leader and if you think
about it the genesis of any movement
comes at the death of another era we
might be able to trace that first spark
back to this moment so this is how
liberty dies
with thunderous applause but while leia
and her mother would live on as the face
of the rebellion in many eras of star
wars history it's true grassroots really
sprung up with another woman from the
clone wars era stila guerrera onderonian
freedom fighter and sister to saw
guerrera who shocked obi-wan and anakin
ahsoka and the clone troopers with their
extremist tactics stila died while
fighting against onderon's droid
garrison and mourned by her brother and
their people as a hero so that years
later in the days after the purge and
palpatine's rise to power as the emperor
sagarrero was one of the chronologically
first people to vocally declare his
defiance to the empire as we saw in bad
match because we refused to fight for an
empire throughout the years of rebels
harris and doula and kanan jairus would
even distance themselves from saw's
terroristic style and as we would see in
rogue one saw guerrera would stick to
his guns to the bitter end on jedha but
speaking of that ghost crew we should
talk about them a little bit because
each of them had their own path to the
rebellion kanan jairus of course was
once jedi padawan caleb doom who in the
opening scene a bad batch fled after the
killing of his master deepavalava hara
syndulla was the daughter of twilight
clone wars era revolutionary champs and
doula but she resisted the empire's
demands to lay down their arms sabine
wren was a mandalorian from the house of
ren who became an imperial cadet
building weapons before defecting ezra
bridger from la fall son of
anti-imperial broadcasters who
eventually were found and taken but
while these various battle lines were
drawn in the trenches diplomatically the
rebellion was forged in the back rooms
with brave senators like baylor ghana
and mon mothma seen in a revenge of the
sith deleted scene we cannot let a
thousand years of democracy disappear
without a fight we are loyalists trying
to preserve democracy in the republic
bale will go on to instill these values
and his adopted daughter leia as we saw
in the obi-wan kenobi series he
encouraged her dereliction of the stuffy
royal lifestyle while grooming her to be
a wise leader nonetheless the sudden
it's boring it's people in itchy clothes
arguing
well
it may seem so i don't want to be a
senator
it is why you'll probably be one of the
best meanwhile bail organa and his wife
brea were secretly pretty involved in
important spycraft specifically bale was
instrumental in recruiting ahsoka tano
back into the fold after saving rex and
escaping order 66 as we saw in the clone
wars season 7 ek johnson's 2016 ahsoka
novel explored her time in exile on rada
where she would begin to plan attacks
against the empire but then after
radha's evacuation she met with bail
organa who talked her into running his
intelligence networks using the code
name fulcrum it was as fulcrum that she
would come into contact with the crew
the ghost captained by harrison doula
relationships that we'll explore further
in live action in the ahsoka series but
we gotta shout out mon mothma she
obviously played a very important role
during these years we caught up with her
in rebels two years before the events of
a new hope when she finally publicly
spoke out in the senate against the
gorman massacre and as a result was
indicted as a traitor ending up on the
empire's most wanted list causing her to
have to flee with the crew of the ghost
but long before that mon mothman did
quite a bit to tutor leia in the ways of
diplomacy that was explored in the 2015
junior novel moving target and of course
we're going to learn a lot more about
mon mothma during these years in the
series andor and during this time mothma
maintained her status in the imperial
senate while recruiting agents like
cassian andor and other saw
guerrera-esque figures like lutheran
rail and marva such a network would
obviously prove instrumental in the
rogue one mission to steal the death
star battle schematics from scarif and
speaking of that mission it's
interesting to note that orson krennic's
kidnapping of galen urso from la mood
forced him to work on what would
eventually become the death star that
detainment happened just three years
before the events of obi-wan kenobi it's
so concurrent to the events of this
series a pre-teen jin erso leaving a
hard life with an outlaw saw gerrera and
his crew the partisans was happening at
the same time obi-wan is on the run with
leia now alongside the partisans were
groups more tied to the criminal
underworld like infast nests cloud
riders who we saw in solo that takes
place just one year before obi-wan
kenobi and one of those cloud riders was
benthic two tubes who would join his
brother edrio twotubes among the ranks
of sagara's partisans in rogue one so
all of these forces are really
intertwined and when we look at it this
way the rebel alliance was an alliance
of really three factions a diplomatic
sector working within the ranks of the
imperial senate to try to win planets
and systems to the rebel cause groups
like by the way different mandalorian
clans who wavered in the rebel support
until united by boca ton until the
empire bombed them all to hell r.i.p the
second faction a loose fleet of freedom
fighters fed intel by figures like
fulcrum and supported by other
sympathetic military factions and then
the final faction rogue terrorists who
take matters in their own hands often at
the ire of the first two groups oh saw
guerrera so leia comes out of this
obi-wan series fitting into the first of
those groups the diplomatic corps but
now we're also learning about another
potentially fourth branch called the
path tasked with getting jedi and force
sensitives to safety while less of an
active branch of the rebel alliance they
are an organization directly subverting
imperial interests allowing a small
number of jedi to live this was made
possible by rokin a widower to a force
sensitive wife as well as people like
tala haja sully wade quinlan vos in the
mapuzo safe house was written the name
doom telling us that caleb doom future
kanan jairus needed this path to survive
and of course without this network we
would not have leia or obi-wan or luke
who yeah played pretty decisive roles in
the downfall of the empire so knowing
all of this who was really the spark who
ignited the flame of the rebel alliance
was it the guerreras or the senators the
path the two tubesis the real answer is
all of them were necessary there are
really one full collective of brave
fools inspiring each other to act but
you know if you're gonna press me on
this we gotta credit one person sorry
guerrera sorry mon mothma in my opinion
it's gotta be bail organa because it was
bale who organized the diplomatic core
baylor looked after leia bale who
reinvigorated obi-wan during his exile
bale who recruited ahsoka and baelou
secured the tantive four in the battle
of scarif and it was bale's martyrdom on
alderaan that turned a bunch of other
systems against the empire without bail
it all really falls apart that is just
the way i see it i am a smith stan i
want to thank you for joining me this
episode of between the duels follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos
following rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you